so I thought we should talk about a game
plan for Halloween Thanksgiving and
Christmas oh I say we follow the Connor
tradition spend every dime we have on
Halloween and then we have nothing to be
thankful for or buy gifts with we have
been through so much this spring and
summer so to be back together again is
such a blessing the cast certainly and
then a lot of the crew or people that
are from the very original run starting
30 years ago it's truly a family so to
get to be around all of them to me is
just you know I'd do it for free it
means a lot to be a part of this iconic
family I watched this family growing up
and I always wanted to sit at the table
I never dreamed so big that I would be a
Connor so now having this opportunity is
fantastic last year I love doing and
this year it's just so great to be back
and the reason the Connors have kept
together there's a families because of
laughter and love it's true there's a
lot of love around here and there's a
lot of love in the show and a lot of
laughter the show is not ignoring the
past at all it's just moving forward and
continuing to evolve it's really about
carrying on the legacy of this show it's
really about taking these characters and
honoring where we come from but then
kind of showing a whole new path I'm
assuming that people will be curious
about the first one and then hopefully
they'll they'll feel like they they're
in good hands with the family there's
definitely things that we're doing that
we obviously haven't explored before
because the dynamics are shifting this
time so different characters step into
different roles you already live here
and you're a scary little tyrant you're
just gonna compliment me and walk out we
felt like we had so many more stories to
tell that I felt like it would be a
shame to not be able to give that to
people
[Music]
you
[Music]